[Music]
guys start talk sports edition I got
another explainer for you okay
Gary and Chuck my co-host from sports
edition thought we'd spend a little time
talking about the banked turns in NASCAR
oh
okay yeah
I'll talk about some money on this show
I'm cool
so the bank turns has a lot of
referencing I mean there's some
similarity to a lip out in golf uh the
physic there's some similar physics
going on I should say and there's some
interesting physics we'll have to say
for a whole other segment not for this
one that relates to the movement of
light through the space-time Continuum
of the universe what
that's another that's I just want to
tease what might be another explainer on
the banked tracks of NASCAR and how it
relates to the space-time Continuum any
racetrack that's any kind of oval that
in that is designed for high speeds
they're going to bank the turn and I
don't know if you've ever been to a
NASCAR race I went I was in Daytona once
and I made sure to catch one and they
invited me down to the into the middle
and I it was fun and and have you ever
tried walking up the bank of that track
no you can't you you you you you it's
like what this is a hill with a slope I
have never walked up in my life okay and
so then you realize oh my gosh what
angle is it what okay I don't remember
the angle but it's higher than your
brain is telling you it should be right
and so you're saying what's going on
here so it turns out
we should ask the question if there were
no bank and your car going into the turn
you weren't relying entirely on the
friction between your tires and the road
Tokyo Drift baby okay
entirely so are you gonna slide out
before you make this turn yes or not
this is what you this is okay and you
have to steer to make sure you stay on
the track always turn towards the skid
people remember that okay so now
but if I put a bank on that turn then
the track is applying a force
at you
inward towards you to the center of the
Arc of the circle of the Arc of the turn
okay okay
so there's a force pointing Inward and
the steeper the track
the greater that force is
as you drive along that track okay
turn signal
so you can calculate the exact angle of
the track
based on how fast your car is going and
what what we say is the radius of
curvature how tight is the turn you
could match those three quantities
so that as you drive into the turn you
don't have to steer at all
the track does your steering for you
but Neil what speed am I doing for the
track to be my magic it depends you need
to Incline to the bank you got to know
that but depends on what the track is
and what the expected speeds are of the
cars the last time I ran this
calculation it was about 180 miles an
hour or something like that for what I'm
describing to take effect okay
you're not you're not going to do it in
your Toyota Tercel basically yeah
because what happens in your in your
Toyota you don't have enough speed to
sustain that and so the car is going to
might fall into the middle and slide
down like as you're trying to go around
it as you're trying to go around how
many racing drivers Neil do you think
are gonna say you know what I've got it
to the speed I need it to be at I'm
going to take my hands off the wheel and
let the bank do the rest
well so none of them but I can tell you
this that if you go higher than that
speed right you run the risk of skidding
off into the embankments and you see
every race that happens and that is why
we watch Nascar okay yes okay so what
I'm saying is the cars that mildly lose
control but not enough to be taken out
of the race and they if they slide off
it's on the bank and they slide up and
hit the upper thing because they're
trying to take the turn too fast yes and
it's and that is true that's when you
see the car and the car like high sides
the they're correct the car is straight
it's totally straight as it's going
around but then you see it high side the
back comes around correct correct and so
it's because that's right because it is
overcoming the the native force of the
Tilted track to turn the car so yeah
that's right so you lose the the the the
frictional connection between your car
and just like the Toyota Tercel that
would just sort of slide down inward on
the track right so so Neil before you
get on to that point remember when we
sat down with Mario Andretti Formula One
World Champion one of my favorite
interviews I had Mario Andretti in my
Hayden planetarium office
[Music]
what did he say about racing I asked him
because I heard this quote and I wanted
confirmed by him he said yes I am
responsible for that quote the quote is
if you are in complete control of your
car
you're not in the race
wow so when the when the when the race
when the Nascar driver comes in at
slightly higher speed he is holding to
the Mario Andretti principle yes yes
correct correct and by the way it's not
a guarantee that you'll always fly off
you're just at higher risk of that okay
yeah depends on you know what your
airfoil is doing your spoiler is doing
and what the design of your underbelly
of the car is what the air currents are
because these all change forces
operating on your car so the point is if
you entered the turn at the speed the
turn was banked for yeah okay
then you do not have to steer the car
and the direction of the car will
completely change with the track look at
that what this means is even if you're a
little lower or a little higher than
that speed basically any steering you're
doing on the track is to maneuver among
the cars not to actually change the
direction you're driving in
this is important because there's an old
joke about about Charlotte okay
Charlotte North Carolina where all
drivers only know how to turn left okay
right because that's the headquarters
for NASCAR and so it's so it's a joke
about this but in fact the track is
doing your steering and not using so it
should be Charlotte North Carolina where
no one knows how to turn at all
exactly no yeah because you're again
you're only turning to maneuver your
place among the other cars right right
which by the way is a better test to the
driver as you're maneuvering I think
right you shouldn't have to worry about
let me change uh turn because the track
is turning now of course in the in the
open wheel sports the Formula One yeah
those tend to be on flat tracks and Neil
they're not always flat there's Hills
there's Banks there's chicane oh sorry
yeah sorry but yeah yeah but they're in
roads it's they're road racing right I
mean yeah it's a trap it's Monaco Monte
Carlo is a road race but the rest of it
is uh
they and they have actual turns they're
actual turns correct where you're not
going 200 miles an hour on the turn you
have to slow really slow down what sort
of friction am I going to need Neil on
my tires to overcome me having liftoff
okay so I want to save that for another
one of these oh teaser because a whole
friction oh my gosh there is no life
without friction tell me about it
oh I wondered where that joke was gonna
go oh I could take it anywhere you want
no I know life without friction we can
start with being a black man and then we
can end up at marriage okay
fatherhood uh wherever you want to be
Richard all right
damn truckers truckers got issues
did you miss your session earlier today
no the truth is I I haven't had therapy
this week guys I'm sorry okay all right
yeah we'll get to that fast
um so uh the point is the the tire
slicks this is just to give it a preview
to what would be our friction segment in
a future show
um
the co it's called a coefficient of
friction
um between a rubber tire and concrete
okay most Road surfaces be it asphalt or
cement is very close to one that's like
the highest coefficient of friction you
can possibly get without having some
other kind of interaction between your
wheel and the road surface okay like
spikes or if the tire is Gummy and is
actually sticking to the surface you can
have a coefficient of friction greater
than one right
and in the tire slicks of drag racers a
drag I know especially there it's surely
also true for NASCAR you ever see when
they warm up the wheels and they they
spin and they'll smoke and if you heat
that rubber it gets tackier right okay
so when you have tacky rubber you can go
coefficient of friction greater than one
which means
the bank of the track can be overcome by
your connectivity to the track itself
so you can take the speeds at higher
than what the advertised banking speed
would give you and not fly off the track
and hit the embankment
nice but more about friction that's a
whole uh
save that because that's uh we learned a
little bit of that with Laurie Winkles
if you remember with geckos and Van Der
Waal forces and things like that so
that's that's going to be fascinating
man my board remembers these shows
couple other things before we break the
undersides of the cars I see what you
did there by the way before we break I'm
just saying I caught it
uh if you have fast moving air
there is lower pressure
than slow moving air
okay
and that's the famous experiment you can
do with a ribbon of paper have you ever
done this experiment uh if you you can
do it at home just cut a ribbon of paper
from a sheet of loose leaf paper eight
and a half by eleven but make it like
two inches across okay and it's got to
be long and Droopy so it can't be like a
postcard or something and let it droop
in front of you and blow above it
and as you blow above it the moving air
has lower pressure than the stationary
air blow it and the paper flutters up
and ends up horizontal in front of your
face so I got a piece sheet of paper
it's just a simple a simple strip a
strip of paper correct correct and
notice there's just dangling down in
front of me and if I sit here and blow
up above it
but all the air is going about it
and so notice for those who could lifts
up and it completely lifts up even
though you're blowing across the top of
it
correct right and so the airflow around
the shapes of these cars
affects that yes and that also affects
the effective weight of the car on the
track which gives you more friction
which is what you want and so so you're
playing you're playing with the mass as
opposed to the white and you know
something oh the mass versus weight are
two different things all right but you
must be are you creating a suction
yes you you can you can create more
weight
on a car's tires without increasing its
mass that's what I was trying to say but
okay it's basically putting your thumb
on the scale yeah
um
yes okay
okay that's a that's a B plus analogy
yeah we can improve on that check yeah
you know
you know if you're pressed down on a
scale you're you're you're you're
heavier but the truth is you're not now
have you ever noticed like just a little
teaser you ever notice the spoilers that
are on cars they're flat on the top and
curved on the bottom you ever noticed
that yes okay that's the opposite of
what an airplane wing does
the airplane wing is curved on the top
and flat on the bottom because an
airplane wants you to go up as it moves
through the air whereas the spoiler on
the back wants the back of the car to
press downward with more force and
increasing the effective weight of the
car without increasing its mass very
important for car racing and it's a
whole that's a whole other thing so guys
that's all we have time for but there's
so much physics in NASCAR that's just
scratching the surface maybe we can do a
few more of these yeah on friction on
the airfoil
on fuel
on on the on accidents we do a whole one
on just accidents there you go let's do
that first please okay Chuck is into the
accidents and how is it that people can
get up and walk away from these
spectacular accidents there's a physics
reason for that I just thought I'd tell
you that's all that's what that's what
makes the accident enjoyable when you
see it
when you see the bad pop out of the cage
and he's like hey everybody I'm fine I'm
like all right all right more of those
yeah
all right this has been another star
talk sports edition explainer Gary Chuck
always good to have you there where's
your nails Neil deGrasse Tyson here
signing off good in you to keep looking
up
[Music]